There is nothing that
makes me happier than biting
into a fresh piece of bread.
This slice is
absolutely fabulous.
In 1932, my grandfather,
Pierre Poilâne,
started his very first bakery.
For over 88 years, my
grandfather, my father, and I
have nurtured half a dozen
shops between Paris and London,
baking between three
and five-thousand loaves a day.
When I was 16, my
mother suggested
that I start my apprenticeship.
While I was finishing
up my apprenticeship,
my parents passed away
in a helicopter accident.
The next day, instead of
going down to the bake house,
I went up to my father's desk.
And here I was in
charge of Poilâne.
In this class, I
will be teaching
you breads that we
do at the bakery.
But the most important
lesson I will teach you
is how to attune
your five senses.
When you're baking bread, you
have four ingredients-- water,
flour, salt, and a rising agent.
You're going to learn
how to bake breads
using sourdough, wheat, rye--
learning how to start
your very own starter.
We will be baking breads of
yeast, pain de mie, cornbread,
brioche, and also what to do
with breads, from its freshest
to its stalest.
Don't be afraid.
It's very easy.
Do not to be discouraged
by failed attempts.
That's what your
journey is about.
Baking really is an essential
and beautiful craft.
Practice these recipes.
Share them.
Spread the love and
enjoy every single step.
Je m'appelle Apollonia Poilâne.
Et ceci est ma MasterClass.